welcome final session of the day
hi
um
who is going to the christmas dinner
tonight
shall we just go mate
i want you i won't hold you for long so
um but this is important topic um
who is building
distributed systems in this room
yeah good so
um for you it will be relevant for those
who don't build distributed systems for
you it will be relevant in the nearest
future because you will be building
distributed systems
um
i don't see like there were more elite
distributed systems monolith disability
system i don't see only twinning so it's
like docker swarm it's i think it will
lose some time in the future
nevertheless even in monolithic systems
the preservability is important
and we will talk through this
soon um
those who've been here or listened to
the virtual conference i gave a talk
industry last year
and the talk was called trace trace open
metrics open telemetry uh open tracing
are we there yet because there was a lot
of things going on at the time and
at 2020
open or 2019 maybe or beginning of 2020
open tracing said
um we're giving up we are joining with
open sensors and we are moving forward
to open telemetry and you come to
openstm2 website and say we are an alpha
stage there is nothing there yet
so you're kind of lost but open tracing
worked and it still works and i gave
some advice to people the video is now
on youtube so if you are in open racing
world you can still get some benefit
from it
um
so we weren't there yet in 2020 but
time flies so we are in 2021 in what is
open telemetry
open telemetry aims to replace certain
things and consolidate them together
in one api one sdk and even more
so
what they want to do
first
they collect
they provide a way to collect traces and
metrics and lock in kind of standard way
and it's all described the spec is
online you can go read it and stuff like
that and it goes across all the
platforms that exist at least it's
supposed to
they want to support as much as possible
drop in instrumentation it means that
you install certain library you write
couple under code and it just gets
instrumented especially for standard
components like asp.net core
grpc
they have instrumentation for sql server
they have instrumentation for stack
exchange radius and stuff like that and
a bunch of contrib libraries that
instrument even more
and all of that you can do by just
installing another package
telling openness to mj i want to
instrument it
and it will work
what it actually delivers so we'll talk
about this in a moment
and it's open source of vendor neutral
so
open telemetry is not a company
it's a standard and it's a consortium of
um of like it's it's a group of people
they have a committee and stuff
which design the spec and the apis and
decide how it should look like and all
the libraries that are built for all the
platforms need to comply to that
which means that there is no vendor
backing it so if you compare it to
vector which has a similar aim but it
does doesn't focus on metrics and traces
necessarily it is kind of more generic
it's it's a company and it's backed by
it it was bought by datadog
without earning a cent of money but
nevertheless
open telemetry is not like that
for example
open274.net was built with a significant
contribution from microsoft there were
several engineers working there and
they're still in a group of maintainers
and approved approving pull requests
so open selection 2021 it's quite
different from what was there before
um
i took this from the
open telemetry website itself so it
doesn't mean that all of that is an
opensclem2.net it's the openc launcher
itself how they explain what they have
for tracing everything is stable except
the collector which is experimental and
what collector is i will explain later i
try the collector it actually works
metrics
with metrics the story is pretty funny
because openclement4.net
0.1 was released
beginning of this year
and it was out of beta
however they removed all the metric code
which was sad because i contributed to
it as well
and they built it from scratch and they
built it in a completely different way
when the epi got feature freeze the sdk
is still experimental but microsoft did
something interesting they actually
built
metric support inside system diagnostic
libraries
the abstraction i will show you how it
works the protocol however is stable and
protocol is something we need to talk
about in a short moment
collector again is experimental i'm not
sure if collectors like some collectors
i think collection of metrics works as
well it's just the number of exporters
maybe is not complete
logging
that's ambitious right we have tons of
different styles of logging i mean we
moved to structured login likely
right microsoft provided their own login
abstraction library and
kind of a nice thing to like drop in
things in logging they didn't manage to
kill ceralog although people expected
them to
um i used surlog personally
plugging into the microsoft logging
abstractions and stuff
however open telemetry aims to kind of
consolidate this as well so provides the
ability for applications to log in
uniformly across different platforms
and shovel it to the centralized login
system in over the uniform of protocol
which replaces all the different
variations of protocols because think
about all these things you have for
microsoft login and sirilogue that quite
a few of them and every each one of them
requires different configuration
and essentially all of that can be
theoretically replaced by a single
collector
so
i won't touch on the protocol just yet i
won't touch
on the collector we will get to this by
the end of the talk what i want to show
is um
because i started to instrument my
libraries in my applications some of the
apps that were built are instrumented
with open tracing
and most of them are instrumented with
promises metrics
and then we like when we built a new app
i said okay let's try open telemetry and
we started instrumented it didn't go
really well and i built this library
that i talked about lately earlier today
adventures event source with event
source in library for net and i
struggled
quite a long time to go through all of
that and reading all the documentation
and stuff like that so
what i found and what i've done i would
like to share it with you today so you
can basically save someone like maybe if
you if i save one hour each for each one
of you it will be a lot of
good environment effect
ah collector here no let's let's keep
this this is like it's supposed to be
demo right
so now i need my bloody glasses
small screen
so what i have here
i have already added
some open telemetry instrumentation
which doesn't instrument anything at all
just yet it's just a basic stuff
there was there are a couple of packages
here
you can see it here one is called open
telemetry exporter alternative protocol
we will talk about this later
and those two are used at the moment no
no none of those i actually use the
implicitly installed open syllabus sdk i
think that's what i use and extensions
for net core to
like register things with a container
so
to add tracing
maybe i'm going a little bit ahead of
train but we will see what tracing is
i'm saying add my traces are tracing
ability to the application
i need to tell it what service name
would be and stuff like that using the
resource builder
and i enable the sampler we'll talk
about a bit later and i say do not
sample anything i want all the data
ingested to my tracing kind of you know
target sync whatever
and i'm adding zipkin exporter zipkin is
a very lightweight tool that i run in
docker container just to show traces on
the screen and for metrics i do similar
thing
and that's brand new it didn't exist
before like two months and it's still in
beta i think
the metrics part but the instrumentation
of apps and libraries using abstractions
from
system diagnostics it's not in beta it
has been released one month ago
when they released dot net six and the
library they provide
it actually has ford 4.05 and 3.1 and
probably even dotnet framework i don't
remember
but here i'm adding from this exporter
so i can i won't run permissions i will
show you just metrics on the screen in
text
and explain what it looks like and then
i have a very simple api
that's just a controller right
which gets this instrumented service
like some service whatever the
repository application service anything
that does some work that involves some
io that goes to the database as such
and it has some delay so
the service
does the job
and you can see what kind of job it does
it just randomly times out or not times
out just waits for a few seconds up to
100 milliseconds
so now i want to know how my service
behaves right i want to see how much
time it takes for the request from the
controller to pass through my service
and get back
so i want to instrument it
um
all right
so what do i do i created a few things
here
first of all i needed to do this thing
it's just the basic stuff right
open telemetry set certain requirements
on how your application needs to report
instrumentation they want to know what
the application
kind of is called
it's the instrumentation name we call we
net
openstamp2.net everywhere uses this
assembly name right but you can just
write any string
as soon as you can find it in your apm
tool
and they want a version
so again they use assembly version in
this case i don't have assembly version
at all so it's probably will be either
empty or zero zero zero
but it's useful because you actually
want to know
which version of your app has delivered
this trace or metric because otherwise
you couldn't distinguish them maybe
there is one version and two other
version running and stuff like that
so
i basically could have used assembly
name because it has a name inside but i
call it my precious because
i like all the rings so that's it
um this one we get back to this later
and this is actually about metrics and
it uses this thing with system.ometrix
which is brand new and shining and stuff
like that so let's let's move to traces
now
the nice thing is that with all the work
that microsoft has done so far i
remember this thing first there was this
event source who remembers the event
source
quite a view okay
remember what it was used to for
push
kind of pseudo logs to event log into
windows right
it changed a little bit and actually if
you say i want to listen to certain
event source
event source is actually an observable
and you can attach an observer to it so
you could decouple thing
so it's actually in some ways a bit
better than microsoft logan obstructions
because if you don't listen to the
observable
there is it doesn't do anything
basically it doesn't report anywhere
so and it's completely decoupled the
bad part is
that sometimes no it's it's about
activities sometimes it's nothing
attached you don't see anything but it's
kind of normal i think i'm saying
something wrong okay nevertheless if you
don't listen to it it doesn't do
anything so it's good
and next thing they've done they created
diagnostic
listener
that implemented the abstract class of
diagnostic source which was pretty
confusing because you have a variable
saying diagnostic source and instantiate
diagnostic listener
and the type that it returns to you is
diagnostic source so it's like for me it
was always confusing the point was
diagnostic listener and the source and
the adapter to it they have a package
with some attributes
that you can publish events a bit
differently so you can wrap it in nicer
api and things like that and you again
can
attach the diagnostic listener to your
diagnostic listener which is a source
which will report events to you and see
things but diagnostic
source
allowed you to attach it kind of
arbitrary payload it kind of pass http
context to it which event source
couldn't do because event source
serializes things to string
always
and that's how we got the first
primitive traces actually so we we
attach using observer
verse
to that source
and say okay now it started and now it's
ended
then they introduced activities
and when people started to implement
activities they said ah that's legacy we
moved to activity source now
and
activities produce
diagnostic events that can be listened
to by diagnostic listeners like
conventions it's something started and
something stopped
so you if you spin up an activity and
start it
it will produce a diagnostic an event
for diagnostic listener that's called
activityname.started
by convention
and then when activity stops it will
produce a diagnostic listener event
that's called active activityname.stop
which is
confusing but still it's like like this
and the activity source is just an
attempt to make the whole thing the
whole story with activities much easier
to work with and this is what i'm using
now
so
i create here in this class that's
called my traces this class is
considered as an instrument by open
telemetry
and
this class needs to be put somewhere so
it gets instantiated because it's not
static and it creates an activity source
that i call source
and it uses the instrumentation name
that is predefined over here my
pressures
and it uses the version which is the
assembly version which is probably now
and of course it can be disposed
so the activity source is a
shortcut
to create new instances of activity that
actually rub the execution of certain
long long running operations with long
running i mean 10 milliseconds or
whatever but it's still
not like it maybe involves some io stuff
like that there's not nanoseconds
so how can i use it in my app
um
not in my app but my instrumented
service
so that's actually pretty simple
i say using var
activity
equals um
oh yeah
so first i need to get this as a
reference public
instrumented service
my traces
choices
and i need to have this
as a field
and then i can say
traces dot source dot star activity
and that's actually it because it has a
parameter
uh which is using the caller name
has the name of the like as as a value
right
it's called um
caller name or something like that it's
an attribute we can specify because the
first parameter is basically the
the operation name
we can space specified explicitly and we
can have some sort of convention but if
you omit it it will just use do the job
as the activity name
and that's it
what this line will do it will start new
activity what activity does
when you create an activity and start it
so activity itself has this api which is
as you can see who used activities at
all
that is pretty useful
so
it's a disposable thing of course
because i'm i have using here and it has
all the stuff that you would need to
associate it with a certain trace right
it has a span id choice study
parent spam the baggage
diagnostic events attached to it
status code and stuff like that
but interesting enough that by the end
of execution of this method activity
will be disposed by the time like when
it disposes it stops
and when it stops it reports how much
time it took for an activity to run
and if you listen to
diagnostic event you will call you can
also extract the duration of your
operation
which is in our case very useful
so
it doesn't seem like much but we can do
something with it now
uh interesting stuff about activities
that
they uh after i do this and when i start
the activity i have access to this
thing that's called activity.current
activity.current would be equal to the
activity instances i just instantiated
they put it in a sync local context so
everything you do
in your method and below
will be within that as in context
so in some other place you can use this
activity current and attach to it as a
parent activity but we'll see how it
works
so
enough code let's see how that actually
works it's not enough of course because
i instrumented my library
but it doesn't mean that it will report
any trace to the application the
application itself needs to know about
this instrumentation so what i do i want
to have this stuff
right let's do two things
so first add instrument
instrumentation my choice
right
when it when you add it like this it
will try to resolve it from the service
provider so it means that i need to
register that as well services at
singleton
my service my traces it doesn't have any
parameters on constructor so it will be
just instantiated
and then i need to say add source
and then give it the activity name so
it's a measures
instrumentation name
so basically if you instrument your
library in a very lightweight fashion
like this
um and and this
i think it will work so let's try it out
what i have here is that
i have a docker compose which runs some
infra including zipkin
so let's see how it goes
um
so this is my test stuff
i have
to try it out and say put something and
it just delays randomly and then it
returns down 10
the 10 i put here and if i go to zipkin
this is a scary moment for me because i
tried it many times sometimes it didn't
work but it worked this time
so
this is the service name
payments right
and this is the done job thing and it
has the library name my pressures
and how much it took to run this service
is 23.9 milliseconds and that's the
thing between 0 and 100 the the time of
my delay
okay now we know how long it takes to
execute the service or instrumented
within the library
what else can we do
well we probably need to put it in the
context of http execution because we're
talking communication right distributed
systems
so
and then this brilliant work that people
have done with opentelemetry4.net
will help us a lot
so what i need to do now and i would say
just add
asb net core
instrumentation
and see what happens
let me close this
and i will do 20
execute
go to zipkin
find a choice
run the query
and i get this
voila
so the first thing that happened is the
http call coming to us using method gets
localhost 5050 as a host the route the
response the target even the url maybe
if you have some secret information here
you shouldn't record it but that's what
open telemetry package does you see here
is the name
and this is our service how this magic
actually happened because we never
associated one but another
this happens
using that thing that i told you the
activity when it gets started it
we do have
it in a sync local context
so what happens is when you say activity
dot start
it will see
do i have something in activity.current
and in the previous example it was null
so it was just one thing
and in this case when i have http called
open selector instrumentation for
asp.net core
it started an activity already
so when my service starts the activity
it attaches
my activity to the one that's already
running so it kind of builds the parent
parent-child relationship between them
and then i see this right
so
what can we do with with this
um
i will show you gigantic span or trace
afterwards but important thing is
that every
this is a trace right
and
every operation within a trace is a span
and it can cross the con the boundaries
of a single service
to do that you need to propagate the
execution context you need to
um
in your let's say you make an http call
to another service
when you do that and at the recent
instrumentation for openclm chief of
http client and for
for sp not core like we see
they will put the current activity
span id and trace id to the headers of
that call and when the other side
receives it they will retrieve it and
spin up a new activity and use it as a
parent
so in this case everything lines up and
you get gigantic traces with a lot of
spans i have it working so i will show
it later but for now what i want to say
okay what about metrics because that
didn't work at all
there are two ways to instrument your
thing with metrics
basically we got in this new thing
in this
system diagnostic metrics namespace
that's called
meter
this one
and meteor doesn't do anything it
doesn't build promises metrics it
doesn't do much it basically a proxy
thing it's an abstraction
for the higher for the implementation to
collect data for metrics
right so it passed through but it gives
you a nice api
so the meter can do
using the meter
which i now create using the same
instrumentation name you can create for
example a histogram metric in this case
i create a histogram of type double
that's called duration this the
description of things and this it's not
description it's a name
and i give it a unit so it's in
milliseconds
so now
what do we need to do with it why this
stuff exists
so there are two ways of basically
collecting metrics so one way if i would
be doing the same as here
i will create a class disposable that
will instantiate a meter
create a bunch of metrics inject this
class to my service
and wrap up the execution of my long
operation into like you know
time watcher or something like that
so then by the end the execution
finishes i will get this time and report
to the metric i already measure it using
the activity right an activity has a
duration i told you
we just not not used it so what you
could do
is to create this nice thing that's
called activity listener
activity listener you can you can create
it yourself
at any time and you specify up to four
functions the first function is deciding
which activity i need to listen to which
activity source i need to listen to
the second one tells how to sample this
in this case i don't sample anything i
want all the data and there are two more
delegates one is activity stop activity
activity started an activity stopped and
these functions will be called for every
activity that fits in these two
conditions
when it starts no one stops it allows
you to fetch data about anything that
happens in the system which is
instrumented with activities
i'm not interested in activity started
because it has nothing for me but
activity stopped already has a duration
so what i'm gonna do i create this
listener
and this is a static thing it says
activity source add this listener right
it's it's again the observable
and activity stop will do a very simple
thing it will take the histogram i just
created and record the duration in
milliseconds
which means that that is not this i
don't need to get this class to my
instrumented service it will just work
if i keep instrumenting my app
so what i do here
i already have metrics here so let me do
this
add
instrumentation
and it will be my metrics
i still need to register though
and then i need to say
add meter
and i need the same measurements
instrumentation name
so you see it's kind of convention based
because it's all
based on observables and observers and
all these things like should i listen to
that
where is it over here see it kind of
checks
and the meter has the same name
so it's kind of decoupled and it's nice
because you don't need to have a lot of
things from system diagnostics inside a
service except of instantiated activity
two lines of code i've done let's run it
and see what happens
let me close it
execute
a couple of times and then i can go to
the metrics endpoint because you've seen
that i enabled promises exporter
from isis exporter
ah
of course i need to add a server that
exposes oh it's already here
it has the promises
scrapping endpoints
the demo effect of course
i'm not sure what i'm running now i
think that's right
now
so
i have no idea what doesn't work because
it worked 10 minutes ago
no
50 50 is it correct yes
nevertheless you have to believe me that
it exposes permission metrics
properly um
maybe because it's release candidate
actually everything here seems to be
instrumented correctly
unless i forgot something no it actually
all is fine
so
[Music]
no it actually worked
i can do one thing here to just confirm
if it works or not without my
instrumentation i can say add
a spin-off core instrumentation because
that's not custom that's default
and i can run it again
and see if they give me anything at all
and they don't
so i guess that's not my fault and
i can blame microsoft for that
yeah
that's kind of sad because metrics are
good
nevertheless
so
let's see how this whole thing works in
the real like more um
how to call it
more comprehensive distributed system
let's just comment it out all of it
and gets to something that i have from
before
like this
i open telemetry and add services
and i skip the rest right
and i need to run another one which is
the booking thing so let's oh that's why
something is badly wrong on my machine
let's see if it runs
payments
yeah i need to keep this one
okay my matrix
okay it works
oh i have too many swagger windows here
opened
so let me try to do some
distributed thing
so i have one service running here which
has some operations
and it's in the vegetable system which
produces events and stuff like that so
let's just create
a booking and uh guest id
and whatever and then put
dates
euro
executed
should work
so let's see what's in zip can now
find a trace
and this is the one right and it already
exceeds what we ever experienced before
it has a lot of stuff because that
system is way more distributed there is
an http call coming in there is a
command handler there is event storage
and there is a consumer side that
projects it to so
here in this system there is an
operation going outside of the single
thread of execution so the http command
gets handled and then afterwards event
gets projected to
database and you will see them all
independently however they all connected
in the single trace
right and you can see that this
operation gp100 already returned the
results to the browser but the operation
is still ongoing because it ex like it
spans over the execution of http call
if we run now
this guy
and say we record a payment which is
another microservice of sorts
and use like
this is the payment microservice
that does its own thing
so everything is right and then we go
find a trace
and let's just run it again
consume
that what was supposed to happen so i'm
able to read events from under 3. yeah i
need to do it again
and we will look at those separately so
this is
the
operation that happened with an error so
when you
have an activity you can tell the
activity to set status to error and in
proper apm tool it will be shown as an
error and you can see exceptions and
everything attached to it if you do it
correctly
openclimate itself has quite a few
extensions for activity class
that allows you to set record exceptions
so you can use opencm sdk for that or
you can use just your own thing
the only thing you need is actually set
a bunch of tags and
apparently most of the api providers can
understand this so these names are
important
if we still now look at the successful
operation you can see
here we go
so that that goes from between two
services we have uh some kind of
collaboration i believe
so here you can see that the the the
single operation exceeds um like i said
the
execution of a single command it goes to
other services and stuff like that what
i can also look at
is the service dependencies
payment's supposed to be here but never
mind so it has the booking stuff and it
has localhost 2113 which is event store
and it has localhost 27017 which is
mongodb
datadock shows it nicer and
aws
x shows it much nicer but this is the
primitive thing already shows the power
of distributed trace because it tells
you how services talk to each other
how you
propagate the context if you look at the
message that i posted through the wire
i propagate remote context by setting
certain tags
and metadata like think about headers in
http requests and stuff like that so you
need a span id you need a trace id these
things you need to get over the wire to
the to the consumer
and then they will be able to create
their own spans and connect them
together and everything looks fine
so
what open telemetry does in addition to
that
they
have an ambition because you see
you work someone worked with prometheus
right i failed to show it
so promisius metrics are exposed in text
and promises is a pool based metric
collection so you instruct promises to
pull certain data sources it goes to the
data source
usually like something the slash metrics
uh it's usually open it doesn't does it
support authorization i don't remember
we usually close this end point only for
internal use
promises call this on channel like five
five seconds ten seconds stuff like that
so it's not like up metrics if ever you
ever worked with up metrics it continues
to accumulate things and then decides to
send it somewhere and it's not like
statsd starts they have a completely
different product called the use udp and
they can continuously push metrics and
in order not to overload
the receiver of metrics they sample them
prometheus doesn't really sample
anything because
it is what we call observable metrics
they call you
so you need to accumulate those metrics
and you need to expose them when the
time comes so when promises ask for it
and it's a text format
statsd apparently uses odp and they use
message pack
elastic uses documents in elasticsearch
you actually need to say index document
then it will go there and provide you
with enough information everyone uses
their own thing and that is kind of a
problem opencelebrity got its ambition
to create a protocol which is jrpc based
supposed to be very very fast
which will do all these things and get
it standardized
so their idea is
that there is a
collector that can
expose receivers
in different formats so they even ready
to receive data in yaga format and
promises format
they will push it through the metrics
pipeline and
trace this pipeline and maybe even login
pipeline and you apply certain things
like you can apply batching and
something inside a collector and you can
create custom authorizations you can
create custom samplers whatever and put
it in the collector
you run collectors and applications so
it's ready-made it's a docker file a
docker container you can actually run it
right
and
on the other side you have exporters
and there are a lot of exporters right
now and i think the number of exporters
will increase so if you look at
openselemc.net for example they have a
bunch of exporters built in and zip can
export a jaggery sport and promise
exporter and some other z pages they
already in there so you can just drop in
the package and worksport like i've done
for zipkin and for prometheus which
apparently didn't work for some reason
but we use data dog in airbox like what
do we do
well
we deployed a collector
we enabled datadog exporter which
supports both metrics and traces
and we started to push our metrics and
traces to the collector instead of
putting it directly to datadog
and it works pretty nicely because then
it's really kind of ender agnostic we
can push from the same collector we can
push somewhere else
like in google cloud or something like
that
so how this actually works
i have the collector running
i will show you how i configured it
so let me stop this thing
collector
[Music]
i have a docker compose file
yeah
you can see it's configured and this is
basically not there are two versions of
course there is the open celebrity
collector and open syllabus collective
contrib that has a lot of exporters and
other things
and i tell you to use my config file and
it exposed the grpc port i think one of
them is legacy another one is new
it's always like that they have quite a
few breaking changes on the go
and the configuration file
is here
and you can take a picture of my api key
but on the free plan it will shut me
down if you misuse it anyway
so it just exports to honeycomb
honeycomb is another thing that just
accepts apm data basically they can only
process traces
i chose it because i can show it
straight away how it works so you can
see here we configure receivers
from the thing is that it is a
collection you can can understand you
can configure more than one receiver
otlp means what openclm should protocol
with that that is generic protocol that
he designed
and it uses jrpc and http we had a batch
processor so it will timeout and collect
batches by 10 seconds
you can do some health pages you pages
whatever extensions
normally you you could basically say i
want kubernetes extensions and they will
collect some metrics around itself
and maybe put some tags that are default
for that node
and here is the configuration for
honeycomb for datadog you would have
something else
for google cloud you probably just set
some environment variables
and i have one thing here
which is the pipeline
i had to remove the metrics pipeline
because it crashed and said we don't
support metrics which is true
and then you say for tracy's pipeline i
have the otlp receiver which is
opencelem2 protocol
i have a batch processor this kind of
pipeline in the middle and i export it
to honeycomb
and i can also export it to logging for
example limit log on a console
so right now when i have it running in
my docker compose
i can say that you
let just limit to something that
actually works
without promises and other things
stop that no actually can keep its
i can go to my add open telemetry thing
and when i'm adding the traces i already
have this hotel otlp
exporter
enabled
and that's probably why i don't see
traces from payment silly me
um so when i was running this operation
so let me just do the same for
the bookings and then we see the full
trace
it's the
openclamatech exporter you see all is
done
these packages are available you can
just scrap them out
and here i have also the jpc protocol
instrumentation which is part of open
telemetry
and what i need to do
in registration here
i need to replace the zipkin exporter
to open telemetry exporter
choose this one
right here
let's run them both
so now i'm not running any vendor
library inside my applications i export
to opengl check on exporter and it takes
care of distributing my traces
using their own protocols whatever
exporters that the vendors have provided
for the open telemetry contrib
so if i go whatever
to
europe
execute that
everything is fine
um honeycomb takes a bit of time to
because again with 10 seconds batching
and stuff like that i have some traces
already reported but i can run a query
and see if my new trace came up
yeah it did
so that's the trace in kanikom let's see
how it looks like
looks a bit nicer zipkin
uh this first thing with the http call
takes longer because it's uh how web api
works i think they resolve dependencies
for controllers on the first call
because they're kind of implicitly
registered
if i do one more request here
i lost my browser sorry
and it will be just another id
there
and everything was fine and let me try
to do the payment because i think
payment service reports to honeycomb
already
record payments
that's too much
and then let's see
how that will go
so i guess that was the second call is
the same one
let's run the query again
yeah
so
that looks a bit more decent
yeah
so this is what we get from a normal
kind of apm provider which is not
zipking because zipkin is too vague
you have a lot of stuff and when you
start browsing through it you have a lot
of tags and you can build new queries
and things like that and if you go to
for example here
in a query they give you a lot of
different things which you can kind of
compose a query with like routes db name
db operation and all the tags here are
kind of default there is a bunch of tags
predefined you can find them all as
constants in opencentury library they're
part of the spec i think
so when you instrument your library you
need to think about all these tags so
other applications understand you
open telemetry api library 4.net
provides also the text map propagator so
when you need to push the metadata to
remote to the context of your http call
or something or the other way around
extract it from it you can use that
propagator but you can also write your
own you just manipulate the headers or
extract data from headers it's pretty
easy to do
so they also suggest you some things for
example this is raw data right and if
you go
what the hell
run the query
ah yeah holy com whatever
maybe i'm not on a paid plan or
something
they have a bunch of stuff so
zip can for example zip code shows you
the service map and data dock shows you
the service map
shall i show our service map once martin
i won't
can't stop me
this is production
there's not
not that we are very proud of what we
have because we haven't instrumented
everything as we should
and i think with open sleims we have a
better chance because they have much
better kind of service name conventions
and things like that
this stuff is instrumented with open
tracing as i believe most of it not all
of it
and if i go to apm service map
so when you instrument your systems you
get something like this but i can assure
you if you do it right you will get it
better
because we haven't done it right there
are a bunch of things that are not
connected to each other
and it should be gigantic thing right in
the middle that's called legacy database
it's not shown so we've probably not
done our job right
but we're going to fix it
the problem here that service names and
arbitration are kind of vague we assign
like this is a legacy database for
position this is a legacy database for
customers this is legacy database for
something else
because they we use the service name
itself as a prefix and a database as a
suffix and that's entirely wrong when
you instrument by default with openclemg
what you get is things like that right
so let me run this query and show our
spans
you see it will use the service name
provided in my code
i see this one add service when you do
the service builder thing
it uses this
over here but when i do the remote call
using the default instrumentation like
jrpc or mongodb you see that it uses the
hostname of the target
and if you call the same host name let's
say my atlas cluster or my
gigantic legacy database it will always
be correct so you will see the gigantic
ball of like ball of mud right in the
middle that everyone is calling to
because it will use a host name
and
like
let's say i need to instrument it with
http client guess what the research
typic line instrumentation library from
open telemetry so that's pretty useful
even if you don't want to instrument
your own libraries you can already use
the instrumentation provided for you
and you will instrument jrpc asp.net
core or asp.net is also supported or dot
that framework web api is supported even
ado.net radius calls
there is a library
that jimmy bogart wrote for opensvm2
that supports instrumenting mongodb
which i use here these are mongodb calls
so it's just a matter of searching for
it and if we look at how many exporters
they have in a collector because you
might say okay there is no exporter in
open telemetry for my apm provider so
what i do
well you can use collector right and
it's like you see i can scroll through
this list
and i'm quite sure if you use some
provider you'll probably find it in the
list
they have everything i think x-ray azure
monitor google cloud
elastic whatever
so
but if you don't do anything at all
which some of you
admitted
so please start doing that because it
will save your day
and hopefully save your night right and
you actually have to do it because
otherwise you don't know how is system
work
i think
that's my last slide
i'm sorry for some
things in a demo it's always shaky when
i do so much online coding but i hope
you got idea
all right that's it questions
am i too early no i'm fine
yeah
so my understanding is that the open
telemetry uh for the next exposures
api but you also in the example you used
using the api from microsoft are there
any benefits
by using either the microsoft api or
open2lmt4.net
is built on top of the things that the
framework using activity and diagnostic
source and new metric api provides
so they use each other
that's why in my instrumentation i only
use the default things i have in my this
in this service
this library which i instrumented
you can see the dependencies for it
and that's the only one
system diagnostics right
i think in.6 i can just remove it and
still be referenced because it's part of
the runtime
so
that's the nice thing because you don't
really need to take the dependency on
that what they they have with guidelines
in opentemp.net saying you would need to
take a dependency on openclave sdk
provided like the open source project
if you want to
[Music]
ensure that you use the same conventions
and tags and everything and you also
want to use api that involves spans and
traces instead of using activity
they are interchangeable because they
use each other and you want to use their
context propagators extraction and
injection but i personally in a ventures
library i wrote my own it took me like
15 minutes it's just it's a dictionary
string object you just read from it
using your own tags or their tags and
that's it it's not that hard
i think by using activities and the new
metric apis they
actually did a decent job on decoupling
things so you don't need to take lots of
dependencies to make it work because for
instrumenting with datadog we have to
take dependency on data.tracer
and we need to take the dependency on
serilog data.sync so we still do it but
when they implement logging we will
remove it as well
so and everything will go through the
collector
so yeah
we tried to use
that and it didn't work
well well we tried jager this excellent
result and we tried the same code with
elastic and
we didn't get
as sort of
nice
diagrams and some things didn't really
work at all like spans so our impression
was that it it really depends on what
you use what ex what exporter you so
from your experience
what you would recommend to use as the
best
thing for discipline
well we use datadog
i don't work for datadog and that they
pay me so i wouldn't recommend datadog
but it's really nice too
um
it's like the problem with datadog that
i found is that it doesn't play
nicely.net should extend at once
so for example they they provide native
opencentral instrumentation for java and
python i think but they haven't done
it4.net and say just go to open tracing
although they know it's obsolete
but we uh work around this using the
exporters
so i think it doesn't really matter
if it's open to them to you or not it's
just search for the best apm provider
that gives you the most value
what i liked about datadog
you can show this this is very nice
i don't i'm not sure if other providers
do the same
but these guys let's say i have
something
like this
like i go to the homepage
it detects stuff
you know and this is the apm this is the
trace
it says that latency was up for more
than four hours yesterday and this is an
usual change in stripper monitors they
actually have some advanced ai that
detects something like that and if i go
to that service
i will see that these are things
and i can look on correlations between
stuff like memory usage and the error
rate and the hit rate and whatever
because it correlates logs from the
infrastructure
infrastructure metrics like cpu usage
and networks and whatever and can
consolidate them all in a very nice
overview
and they even like there if i use their
own
serilog sync
for editdoc and i have tracing enabled
and i can i think we wrote it ourselves
actually so we use data doctor lock sync
and we have activity running
we just say everything we log within the
context we'll get a span id and trace id
and netdocks can correlate traces with
logs and if you get error trace you
click on it you see the logs below it's
it's really nice
i think most of the providers do the
same it's just a matter of how it kind
of
works all together so if i look at no
not trace services list
and let's uh take this one
which is not that good
um
if i click on this one i think this is
the most brilliant thing ever i'm lazy
person i don't want to figure out what
monitors i need for that particular
service they say we have
six suggested monitors and you can
decide which one you want to enable and
if i enable one
they will tell me if something goes
wrong
and they have a bunch of ways to tell
you like the simplest would be slack and
another would be pagerduty integration
and opportunity or whatever else which
is cool
and i can do that right
that's it
i'm a devops person now
and i have a bunch of things to
configure and like this is really good
and um
again if you are in a single cloud you
might find that your cloud provider has
very good tooling if you're multi-cloud
or you're on prem you might find out
that like more a cloud agnostic vendor
like datadog
could provide you a better experience
okay
anything else
well good
everyone everyone wants to go for dinner
and drink some beer
all right thank you very much thank you
for your patience
[Applause]